what's going on guys this is rob and i
just want to touch base with you guys i
don't know why i laughed about that i
don't like that's funny to me but i just
wanted to talk today about smiling i
want to talk today about laughing and
just kind of having a good time because
you know i think that that I don't know
what it is let me let me back pedal here
let's back pedal a little bit kind of
talk about why I wanted to do this video
in the first place so one of my favorite
pastimes it's just kind of like scroll
through YouTube and just look at like
weird videos and funny videos and I know
that can be dangerous because if you
click on the recommended videos long
enough you'll end up in some very weird
places on youtube like like that part
like that part of YouTube the part that
everybody avoids it's really kind of
funny because I'll see one of these
videos and I'll look down in the
comments and somebody else say well
that's enough internet for me today no
no just I guess sign off i don't know
but it was really kind of funny cuz i'll
scroll through videos and i was looking
at one of PewDiePie's videos and i think
he googled himself or something like
that and you know i don't want this to
be a video where I'm just like hey this
video is about PewDiePie because maybe
he'll notice me and you know any he'll
be like hey that guy's cool and then you
know or something like that you know
it's just you know I like the idea of of
people like taking time out of their day
to make other people happy you know and
its really kind of interesting to me
because I think that that you know in
this day and age you know the world
moves a million miles an hour you know a
lot of you guys who are still in school
you guys have so much stuff going on I
mean a lot of you guys you know you guys
got your like bombarded by social media
from like every direction like I don't
even know if you guys use you know
myspace anymore but you know I mean back
when I was younger you know use myspace
all the time in my space suit would just
like bombard you I mean you just like
everybody was on MySpace and I'm pretty
sure a lot of you guys are using like
Facebook now I'm you know I'm i use
facebook for like the Marvel explained
or for the most part like I'm out of
touch with like the current forms of
social media i know there's like Twitter
you know I used Twitter every once in a
while you know and I tweet I tweet stuff
out when Twitter first came around I
thought it was silly I was like really
like tweeting that we were doing that
like we're just tweeting soft like okay
whatever let's just get on with it so
but um you know it's really kind of
funny because you know the world is
crazy now I mean you got people who are
parents you know you've got people who
have both parents in the household but
their jobs are so busy and so demanding
they just don't have time for anything
else you know you've got a generation of
kids that are raising themselves and you
just got you know so much going on in
the world today and it's very easy to
get caught up it's very easy to really
kind of get yourself in a place mentally
where you're just really kind of I guess
you feel beat down you just kind of feel
you know like the world is just beating
the hell out of you and there's just
nothing you can do to stop it and so
it's really good we can come across
something like you know like a pewdiepie
video on youtube or any kind of youtube
video for that matter you know and then
something that just kind of you know
makes you laugh because that's what I
try to do you know how do these video
blogs you know I love to feel like
laughs you know I think it's funny to
laugh I don't know why I don't know why
it's just you know like laughing is fun
you know I mean there's no reason not to
laugh I mean there's always something to
laugh about you know even if like like
one of the funny things and now I can't
be the only one that used to do this but
like I would be in high school and even
now like like I'll think about something
funny and I was laugh to myself and
people look at me weird like they're
like like what the hell do you have to
be happy about and it's just funny to me
like I do that all the time in high
school people would think I was weird
but it would just be something funny i
just couldn't help but laugh about it
and you know it's a great feeling you
know to laugh it's a great feeling you
just kind of you know giggle to yourself
and to me it's a very stress relieving
thing it's a really good way to to
release just you know because as you
guys know i mean this this whole YouTube
thing is like in conjunction with my job
so like there been times where I've gone
to work with like four hours of sleep
with three hours of sleep because I've
been up all night trying to get a video
together so you know it's very easy to
get stressed out in life these days and
and the one important thing that I would
say to you guys is just find time to
relax you know just find time to you
know just kind of have thoughts to
yourself even if you choose to just kind
of sit in the dark by yourself and just
kind of you know meditate I guess I mean
that wouldn't really interest me too
much but you know I mean for me like
like a really good way for me to
meditate into chill it's to sit in my
den back there you know in my man cave
you know on my recliner chair and to sip
you know some some alcohol or something
like that you know like just kind of not
like a big glass you know but like just
you know a shot you know and just kind
of relax and maybe watch like a movie
watch you know ocean's twelve or ocean's
oceans 13 oceans 12 is my favorite of
the oceans
movies a lot of people think I'm crazy
because of that slide oceans 12 my god
man like how do you know taste in movies
whatsoever but you know it's just you
know fine time just kind of kick back
and chill fun time to you know if you
can you know to just kind of relax and
just understand that you know everything
really kind of has to be done one thing
at a time you know that was really kind
of my success in terms of just like you
know life in general just kind of taking
things one at a time people will try to
rush you people will try to say this
needs to be done now you know into a
degree sometimes that's out of your
hands especially in the workplace but
you know if you can you know just kind
of chill you know and laugh and have a
good time and just remember don't take
life too seriously because you'll never
get out alive so I heard that phrase
once and I thought it was kind of funny
but um I don't know it's just you know
it's it's I feel like I'm rambling at
this point but I don't mind rambling I
don't mind when I'm going on with you
guys but you know it's just um you know
when I was younger when I was in high
school it felt like like everything had
to be so serious like everything was
just like a great big huge great big
deal like everything was a big deal you
know like I asked him girl out she says
no it's like my whole world comes
crashing down you know my homework
respond i didn't get done in time the
whole world comes crashing down you know
it was just it was one of those things
where it's just like like everything is
a huge deal and it's so easy to get
stressed out and it's so easy to just
feel stretched so thin and so you know i
think it's important that people take
time to really kind of you know pull
themselves together for me if it's
philosophy like i love reading about
philosophy i mean i've got you know the
complete works of aristotle you know
like back there on the bookcase you know
i mean i've got you know let's see I've
got jean-jacques rousseau I've got
Tocqueville I've got all these different
kinds of you know philosophers and
historians because I loved reading about
that element of history of society you
know I love seeing the mindset i was
seeing the perspective of the world from
someone's viewpoint I like seeing you
know reading about you know Alexander
Tocqueville and as you know his tour of
the united states post Civil War you
know and how he viewed the United States
you know how is it the United States
appears get people from the other side
of the world and so to me it's really
just kind of a chance to relax and it's
really just kind of a chance to just
slow down
and to stop and catch my breath you know
because I think we all kind of really
need to do that I think we all sometimes
just need to stop and catch our breath
but anyway I feel like I'm rambling on
long enough um it is currently July 4th
and is three almost four o'clock in the
morning so I know a lot of you guys are
going to be out and doing crazy stuff
and then having a good time and that's
cool you know celebrate them fourth of
July you know just be responsible about
it you know be safe I know there's going
to be a lot of police checkpoints and
that's cool that's necessary on to make
sure that that we keep dangerous people
off the road but you know if you guys
are going to drink then do so in the
company of friends you know dude around
people that you trust and of course you
know don't don't drink and drive don't
get behind the wheel of a car and you
know just make sure that wherever you go
that you're traveling with friends k
something happens you know that you'll
have people that can help you out so you
know just have a safe fourth of July
weekend you guys I know I'm going to be
out and about i'm going to be partying
tomorrow i guess later on today I'm
gonna be hanging out with a bunch of
friends and I probably will be drinking
but you know I'm actually gonna be
hanging out with my dad as well this
weekend he's coming up from Tennessee
and so that's really gonna be kind of a
cool thing and and yeah so i guess i'll
go ahead and bring this video to an end
but i'll catch you guys later peace